in the early 2000s britney spears was on
top of the world
she had a string of platinum number one
albums
she was nominated for grammy awards she
went on
a series of world tours that rose tens
if not hundreds of millions of dollars
each
and in 2002 forbes named her the most
powerful celebrity in the world
with an estimated 40 million dollars of
income before taxes and fees
compared to her contemporaries like
jessica simpson or jennifer lopez she
was miles ahead
not only in terms of star power but in
terms of earnings she's sold more
concert tickets and more albums than
either and
and to this day actually remains ahead
of them in both of those metrics
court documents reveal that spears is
currently worth 60 million dollars
that may sound like a lot at first but
it's not when compared to others in the
industry
jennifer lopez and jessica simpson are
each worth over 100 million dollars
and newer stars like rihanna beyonce and
taylor swift are each worth over 350
million dollars
so why does one of pop's biggest stars
lag behind her peers
in 2008 after many years of
media scrutiny and a public mental
breakdown
britney was put under a court-ordered
conservatorship that basically means
that a judge handed control over her
person
and her career and finances to what's
called a conservator and in this case
her father james was that figure
he's kind of become the villain of the
fan driven free brittany movement that
seeks to free britney of her
conservatorship at first the setup
didn't affect her career much and
appeared to be working
in the decade following the
implementation of her conservatorship
she released four more albums around
four world tours
and had a las vegas residency that
grossed 137 million dollars
but around 2015 she stopped appearing in
television commercials
she was once a super popular choice for
endorsements
she had a multi-year multi-million deal
with pepsi
you might remember those super bowl
commercials she hasn't released new
music since 2016
and in 2018 she stopped touring in 2019
she called off
what was supposed to be her second las
vegas residency that would have seen her
earn at least
350 000 a night there's no way to know
why these decisions were made
but we do know that recently in court
brittany's lawyer said she's afraid of
her father and she will not perform
again until her father is not in charge
of her career
an attorney for jamie spears defended
his control over britney's career
even claiming that brittany was in debt
prior to the conservatorship
but spears's inability to steer her own
career and now her refusal to work
raised questions about what britney
could have done without her father
and in addition to that she spent
millions of dollars on her legal fight
as part of the conservatorship she pays
for not only her lawyers
but her father's lawyers she pays a fee
to her father
and she has to pay millions in child
support as well to kevin federline
in february a judge ruled against jamie
spears allowing bessemer trust to
control
50 of britney's finances giving them
equal rights to jaime
you